ce qu'on voit c'est qu'ils ont de vrais
volonté d'aller rivaliser avec des
géants comme apple comme ça le soum très
clairement avec cette solution là on
voit qu'ils cherchent un marché sur les
plates-bandes d'apple sur une
connectivité extrêmement rapide et
transparente sur deux device de la même
marque donc ça c'est franchement très
intéressant le fait de pauvres
[Musique]
il ya quelques mois je vous emmener avec
moi à vegas pour pour vous ouvrir plein
plein plein plein de choses le cfcv
c'est un peu le temple de toutes les
nouvelles technologies et aux 6es je
vous ai parlé du nouveau huawei macbook
13 pouces il est là il est beau il est
chaud je suis très content parce que cet
ordi ce petit tandis qu'on pas que cet
ultraportable est vachement intéressant
déjà parce que c'est une belle bécane
elle est pas hyper cher le prix est
plutôt intéressant je vais vous
expliquer comment il est je vous donnais
mon ressenti ce qu'il est bien pas bien
c'est ça qui sortent je te kiffe pas
achement vachement intéressant c'est le
huawei cher on peut l'utiliser avec son
p 30 pro avec d'autres smartphones
également de chez huawei pour lui
d'avoir le petro par le pétrole pour
avoir le nez de 20 provinces
je vous expliquais c'est hyper cool et
je vais vous montrer surtout un truc est
vachement intéressant qui n'est pas
encore tout de suite sans le marché mais
qui va arriver fin mai 2010 neuf c'est
ce qu'on peut faire avec le huawei cher
on peut déjà faire des choses mais leur
retard
vachement de choses c'est vraiment super
intéressant et vous allez voir que ça et
ça ça communique très facilement ça
fonctionne parfaitement bien ensemble
c'est un écosystème qui est complètement
cohérent c'est vraiment top tout de
suite on va d'abord commencer par
regarder cette petite bête
du point de vue du design vous avez tout
un cadre en aluminium qui est
franchement bien petit logo wl cul
plutôt cool c'est franchement
l'ordinateur qui est bien bien réussit
il est hyper léger il fait à peine 1 kg
3 très très très épuré vous avez ici une
petite prise dia qui est concerné ça
c'est vachement bien elles et leurs
charges et ici en usb c'est plus branché
toutes vos connectique que vous
souhaitez avoir directement la à
l'arrière absolument rien vous avez
également un autre usb c'est qu'ils se
situent juste live vous avez un haut
parleur l'a et un autre haut parleurs là
pour l'audio donc assez cool petit haut
parleur sur le dessous lorsque vous
l'ouvrez vous découvrez un ordi qui
franchement sympa écran complètement
tactile vous voyez au niveau du design
c'est vraiment réduit on arrive vraiment
presque au bord s'est complètement
optimisé le capteur d'empreintes
digitales aussi est très bien placé très
pratique il déroule très rapidement
consulter cet ensemble je pose mon doigt
qui déverrouille directement c'est hyper
rapide un clavier qui est franchement
bien les touches sont suffisamment grand
un truc est sympa aussi c'est qu'ils s'y
voyaient petite led très discrète pour
savoir si votre bouton enfoncé pareil
pour cette touche là il est vraiment
hyper agréable à utiliser super retour
de touche
les touches sont pas trop petit c'est
vraiment très très agréable le trackpad
est assez grand il est très long il va
prendre toute une majeure partie de la
zone pour pouvoir l'utiliser autre gros
point positif sur cette machine et son
écran tactile pouvez utiliser bien
évidemment avec vos doigts faire ce que
vous voulez pour naviguer pour ouvrir
pour fermer c'est très pratique
l'écran est plutôt bon assez lumineux
c'est pas les francs le plus contrastée
c'est un écran qui est très honnête ça
sera pas à l'écran le plus dingue qu'on
puisse trouver sur le marché par contre
trouve qu'il est bien il fait
franchement bien la faire et dans cette
gamme de produits
franchement il n'a pas du tout à rougir
on a un écran tactile une dalle y ps et
un écran qui fait 2660 par 1440 pixels
vous avez souvent intel core i5 8 gigas
de ram 256 go de stockage en ssd soit en
intel core i7 c'est ce que j'ai ici 8
gigas de ram également et 512 giga en
ssd là forcément vous avez des tarifs
vous vous en douterez le premier tarif
avec intel core i5 vous êtes un peu
moins de 1000 euros 999 euros voire 899
euros en fonction des promos dispo sur
internet d'ailleurs si vous intéresse
vous ai mis un lien en bas dans la
description et celui ci il 7 8 gigas de
ram 512 giga de stockage vous trouvez à
peu près mille 100 euros je vous ai mis
également un lien ma dans la description
il à un tarif assez intéressant ce
moment entre point intéressant vous avez
une toute petite webcam qui se loge au
ici on y re communiquer sur sky sur ce
que vous voulez elle est là c'est très
pratique et il tombe sur un windows
disent personnellement c'est un produit
que j'aime bien je trouve
compact petit discret silencieux il fait
le job il ya suffisamment de puissance
notamment avec lé intel core i7
l'autonomie est pas mal on le garde six
à sept heures en utilisation assez
intensive
attention cette bécane vous allez
l'acheter pour de la bureautique pour
faire tourner des applications regarder
des films
vous allez pouvoir faire multiplace pas
mal de choses avec il avoir des limites
avoir des limites notamment sur tout ce
qui va être édition de vidéo vous allez
pouvoir faire et tout petit montage mais
pas des trucs de dingue vous n'allez pas
pouvoir aller bien loin avec uniquement
8 gigas de ram
c'est pareil pour la retouche photo dès
lors vous allez aller très loin avec du
multi calque ya un moment ça va être un
petit peu les limites par contre pour
tout le reste ça va être vraiment bien
c'est une bonne machine pour faire
mettre pas mal de choses avec qui ont
plus
ça ne chauffe pas particulièrement en
usage intensif est assez silencieux
le duo est pas mal même s'il est pas
complètement fou vous avez un son qui
est un petit peu trop médium je vous
pousse le son à fond
il ya quand même suffisamment de
puissance par contre je trouve que pour
ma part c'est en dessous que trop médium
par contre du point de vue le dos il ya
un truc qui marche
vachement bien je gueule un peu parce
que là j'entends absolument rien c'est
le casque le faux est vraiment cool
il ya un excellente qualité audio au
casque donc ça c'est plutôt bien qu'on
veut nous et conserver une prise jack
qui en plus fonctionne bien envoie du
steak gros point positif
comme je le disais vous leur charge et
bien évidemment la en usb titre ça c'est
cool mais surtout ce qui est très
intéressant et très bien comme vous le
savez cet ordinateur la ajuste de l'usbc
donc on pourrait se dire ah mince pour
pouvoir tout branché que nenni huawei a
pensé à tous nous a fourni un petit lob
usb c'est vous brancher sa à votre
ordinateur en usb c'est l'autre côté
vous avez accès à de l'usb type à vous
avez du hdmi vous avez vous êtes
vraiment tranquille une machine qu'est
donc compact polyvalente performante
le clavier cool lo'jo est sympa le cran
est plutôt bien en tactile ça fonctionne
parfaitement bien il n'est pas hyper
cher c'est un bon produit tu mens plus
de ça il ya tout qui est vraiment génial
c'est waou et cher ouaouicha je vais
vous montrer ce qu'on peut faire avec
alors je vous dis tout de suite ce que
je vais vous montrer n'est pas
disponible tout de suite sur le marché
ça arrivera femmes et 2019 et vous allez
voir ce qu'on peut faire avec c'est
bluffant route les et maraîchères il
vous faut déjà d'un petit bout 13 votes
n'est bouteresse est dur à prononcer
netbook 13 là c'est bon je les paie 30
pro à partir du p 25h l'appairage se
fait en nfc et ensuite ils vont
communiquer tous les deux en vous allez
voir c'est très simple il vous faut un
smartphone mis à jour avec émotion nuit
9.0 et votre pc doit avoir baissé
manager 9 points qui sera disponible
uniquement à partir de fin mai bon j'ai
la chance je les en avant première ça
c'est intéressant très content parce que
je suis un des rares français à la voir
en avant-première donc ça c'est vraiment
cool
première chose à faire se connecter pour
le pose ici pour le fcg une vibration et
là il me marque mais book 13 n'ont
trouvé se connecter je me connecte
mellouk 13 connectés ok on peut y aller
premier cas d' usage qui vraiment
intéressant je prends mon smartphone
jusqu'où je le pose là il vibre il va
communiquer directement en nfc et là
vous voyez ici on retrouve mon écran
donc là je peux naviguer je peux faire
tout ce que je veux et lui il va
exactement enregistrés ce qui est en
train de se passer sur mon ordinateur
voyez je naviguais je me déplace je
ferme jour j'ai exactement la copie de
ce qui se passe sur mon ordinateur sur
mon smartphone et sam l'enregistrant
vidéo donc pas voir une vidéo d'une
minute maximum dans lequel je vais avoir
exactement toutes les infos qui a entre
mon ordinateur et mon smartphone ensuite
lorsque c'est terminé up paf vous
appuyer là ça vous l'enregistrent dans
votre galerie il vous pouvez la regarder
à volonté alors bon regardez juste
ouvrir et fermer cela globalement très
très très peu de sens par contient plein
de cas d'usagé vachement intéressant
autre exemple qui est vachement
intéressante je l'aï dans la galerie je
vous ai sélectionné une photo que j'ai
prise à toulouse il ya à peu près dix
jours je veux que cette photo elle parle
directement dans mon ordinateur et ben
c'est hyper simple je le prends je pose
hop ça me transfère directement elle
apparaît là et c'est vraiment génial
c'est instantané
hop et je peux en faire d'autres
voiliers venus note qui est juste là je
prends la même manière je pose sommes
bien en face petites vibrations et elle
part directement donc là ce que
transférer tout le contenu y perd
facilement faire ce que je veux comme je
le veux garder pardon cette photo que
j'ai prise avec mon p 30 prono x to
separate la même manière je vais venir
le posez là hop ça l'envoi et je la
retrouve directement en face sur mon
ordi donc là je vous a fait la démo avec
la communication de mon smartphone vers
mon pc mais je peux le faire dans
l'autre sens là j'ai une photo qui est
sur mon ordi je me transférer dans mon
smartphone très facile gelé ouvert ici
dans mon application je pose mon
smartphone la petite vibration
ça va me l'a transférée elle est là
offre et voyez j'ai récupéré directement
mon image de mon ordi à mon smartphone
autre exemple je sois une capture
d'écran de ce que j'ai directement sur
mon ordinateur
et bien je le prends je le pose et hop
ça transfert ça fait une capture d'écran
et là je récupère ici l'image que j'ai
sur mon ordinateur
donc tout ça c'est hyper cool maintenant
on peut aller encore plus loin faire des
trucs encore plus hallucinant vous allez
voir c'est vraiment cool par exemple là
je suis sur youtube sur ma vidéo du
pétrole pro sont mon test que j'ai
réalisé il ya pas très longtemps et je
veux faire une capture d'écran vous
allez voir ce qu'on peut faire
donc la fin d'une capture écran de ma
description ici de mon texte
capture d'écran c'est facile toc toc hop
ça ne fait une capture d'écran ici j
capture d'écran qui est là je la pose je
la transfère directement up de l'autre
côté elle arrive sur mon ordinateur et
c'est là que ça devient très intéressant
je vais cliquez ici c'est reconnaître du
texte hop
et là ça m'a reconnu tout le monde texte
alors il ya du texte dont je me moque le
début par exemple ça je m'en fiche ça
m'intéresse pas mais je veux récupérer
tout le reste de mon texte je vais bien
récupérer le texte
huawei début de l'année sur les chapeaux
de roues avec des magnifiques morceaux
gna gna gna gna gna
j'ai exactement la même chose ici donc
je peux sortir du texte directement à
partir d'une capture d'écran faite
directement sur mon smartphone mais
c'est pas tout parce que ça c'est quand
même plutôt sympa on va dire ok ça c'est
rigolo je suis d'accord mais regardez
par exemple je prends ce texte là je
vais faire un copier up contrôle c je
vais arriver directement sur mon
smartphone je me crée un google docs et
là je fais hop je laisse appuyé collet
et ça me colle le texte directement
depuis mon ordinateur directement là
parce que eux deux communique en
permanence
donc je vais pouvoir faire une capture
d'écran ici l'envoyer là bas extraire le
texte faire un copier et ça va le coller
directement et tous les textes
maintenant que je vais m'y recopier sur
mon ordinateur vont être collé
directement si je le souhaite sur mon
smartphone et ça c'est franchement juste
incroyable alors sous le coup comme ça
c'est vrai que ça peut paraître un peu
gadget mais si on réfléchit à tous les
cas usage quand on a besoin d'extraire
du texte à partir d'une photo que ce
soit à parfaire votre ordinateur à
partir de votre smartphone
que vous vouliez le texte sur votre ordi
ou sur votre smartphone vous communiquer
en temps réel et c'est là qu'on voit la
puissance de vos richert mais s'en sort
vraiment très intéressant
autre truc qui est vachement bien j'ai
un document word par exemple qui est ici
sur mon ordinateur et je veux l'envoyer
directement sur mon smartphone pour
pouvoir l'éviter sur voire de la même
manière alors j'ai pas avoir de là
dedans mais je vous demande vous allez
voir comment ça fonctionne je prends mon
document mon document point doc jeu
louvre directement dans word là y'a pas
grand chose dedans j'ai un petit texte
marqué test aux tests j'aime le grossir
pour vous puissiez le voir un peu plus
gros voilà j'ai un gros test qui est là
je prends mon smartphone je pose la
vibration ils communiquent et là ils
m'envoient directement le document point
d'orgue qui est là et j'ai mon point
d'orgue directement en stockage interne
et ça c'est franchement coulon ça veut
dire que si j'ai ward à l'intérieur je
tenais à l'éditer vous faites avec un
point doc pouvait faire avec un pdf
enfin tout est vraiment très intéressant
de la même manière j'ai supporté vos
fichiers word en pdf
il est là avec le grotesque au milieu il
donne la même manière je viens posé là
j'ai ma petite vibration mon transfert
qui se fait avec mon fichier qui est là
gémo pdf jeu peut l'ouvrir et là j'ai
bien mon fichier test en pdf donc vous
le voyez ce qui est génial c'est qu'on
ait une communication qui s'était
directement entre votre smartphone votre
paie tremperont votre paie 30 votre père
un pépin pro ce que vous voulez pas ce
que vous voulez à quelque chose près il
faut pouvoir avoir une motion lui 9.0
vous allez communiqué très facilement et
après tout est stocké ici à l'intérieur
dans vos documents
huawei donc c'est franchement hyper
génial et comme ça à l'écran tactile paf
je peux le faire avec moi donc je trouve
que c'est vraiment bien d'un côté vous
avez un ordinateur qui est bien qui est
compact c'est un ultra portable de
huawei qui fonctionne bien on intel core
i7
c'est parfait c'est merveilleux 512 giga
de stockage en ssd pour moi ça
fonctionne parfaitement bien on a une
bonne bécane qui est intéressante mais
qui coûte à peine plus de 1000 euros
donc ça va en termes de prix il est très
bien placé et surtout ce qui est génial
c'est toute cette possibilité de
productivité que vous avez entre votre
paie 30 pro et votre ordinateur votre
macbook 13 parce que ce qui fait la
force de cette solution c'est pas juste
le fait de se dire voilà on conduit
comme ça c'est rapide c'est pratique
mais on voit qu'on a un écosystème
ce qu'on voit c'est qu'ils ont une vraie
volonté d'aller rivaliser avec des
géants comme apple comme samsung très
clairement avec cette solution là on
voit qu'ils cherchent à marcher sur les
plates-bandes d'apple sur une
connectivité extrêmement rapide et
transparente sur deux dit vague de la
même marque donc ça c'est franchement
très intéressant le fait de pouvoir
enregistrer d'un côté de l'aude de
transférer de tous les côtés tout ce
qu'on veut du texte en copié-collé
extrêmement rapidement de partager des
documents de faire des captures d'écran
fin c'est vraiment génial moi tout ça
vraiment très intéressant vous avez tant
dire ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire qu'est ce que vous pensez
déjà dans un premier temps de se mettre
book 13 2019 est ce que vous trouvez
intéressant oui non pas comment le fait
d'avoir l'écran tactile dans cette gamme
de prix pour pas oublier qu'on est quand
même aux alentours de 1000 euros est ce
que vous trouvez ça intéressant vous
pouvez la voir on y 5 à 2 899 euros
actuellement sur internet d'ailleurs
site internet une fois de plus si un
lien dans la description avec un écran
tactile faut pas oublier donc ça se
trouve ça vraiment bien positionnés en
termes de tarifs cette collectivité avec
huawei cher est ce que vous trouvez que
c'est un sens cette collectivité avec
moi ou mes chers qu'est ce que vous
voyez
usage qu est ce que vous pourriez faire
avec et est ce que vous pensez que vous
pourriez client est ce que ça vous
intéresse
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire ce rendez-vous dès demain
avec plein de nouvelles infos d'actu
take vous allez voir il ya de belles
surprises qui arrive à bientôt ciao
[Musique]